rents bicycles to tourists she recorded
the height in centimeters of each
customer and the frame size in
centimeters of the bicycle that customer
rented
after plotting her results vera noticed
that the relationship between the two
variables was fairly linear so she used
the data to calculate the following
least squares regression equation for
predicting bicycle frame size from the
height of the customer and this is the
equation so before i even look at this
question let's just think about what she
did
so she had a bunch of customers and she
recorded given the height of the
customer what size frame that person
rented and so she might have had
something like this
where in the horizontal axis you have
height measured in centimeters and the
vertical axis you have frame size that's
also measured in centimeters and so
there might have been someone who
measures a hundred centimeters in height
who gets a 25 centimeter frame i don't
know if that's reasonable or not for you
bicycle experts but let's just go with
it and so she would have plotted it
there maybe there's another person of a
hundred centimeters in height who got a
frame that was slightly larger and she
applied it there
and then she did a least squares
regression and at least squares
regression is trying to fit a line to
this data oftentimes you would use a
spreadsheet or to use a computer and
that line is trying to minimize the
square of the distance between these
between these points
and so the least squares regression
maybe it would look something like this
and this is just a rough estimate of it
it might look something so let me get my
ruler tool
it might look something like
it might look something
like this so let me plot it so this
that would be the line so our regression
line y hat is equal to one third plus
one third x
and so this you could view this as a way
of predicting or either modeling the
relationship or predicting that hey if i
get a new person i could take their
height and put it as an x and figure out
what frame size they are likely to rent
but they ask us what is the residual of
a customer with a frame
with a height of one 155 centimeters who
rents a bike with a 51 centimeter frame
so how do we think about this
well the residual is going to be the
difference between what they actually
produce and what the line what our
regression line would have predicted so
we could say residual let me write it
this way residual
is going to be actual
actual minus
predicted
so if predicted is larger than actual
this is actually going to be a negative
numbers predicted is smaller than actual
this is going to be a positive number
well we know the actual they they tell
us that they tell us that they rent
it's a the 155 centimeter person rents a
bike with a 51 centimeter frame so this
is 51 centimeters but what is the
predicted well that's where we can use
our regression equation that viewer came
up with the predicted i'll do that in
orange the predicted is going to be
equal to
one-third plus one-third times the
person's height their height is 155.
that's the predicted y hat is what our
linear regression predicts our our line
predicts so what is this going to be
this is going to be equal to 1 3 plus
155 over 3 which is equal to 156 over 3
which comes out nicely to
52.
so the predicted on our line is 52 and
so here
so this person is 155 we can plot them
right over here
155 they're coming in slightly below the
line
so they're coming in slightly below the
line right there and that distance which
is
and we can see that they are below the
line so the distance is going to be or
in this case the residual is going to be
negative so this is going to be negative
1. and so if we were to zoom in right
over here you can't see it that well but
let me draw so if we zoom in let's say
we were to zoom in the line and it looks
like this and our data point is right
our data point is right over here
we know we're below the line and it's
just going to be a negative residual and
the magnitude of that residual is how
far we are below the line and in this
case it is negative one and so that is
our residual this is what actual the
actual data minus what was predicted by
our regression line